something feels good I'm warmer not was
yesterday I'm gonna say the same thing
bottom line time's running out and we
need more fish always more fish we've
got to support my family I got to pay my
crew I have to maintain my boat and I
have to try to save some money it's a
tall order but I'd do it every year
20,000 more lotta more let's get on top
of these pitch boys I want to do
everything I can to help my dad ain't
Cain I'm still learning kind of learn
every day but all about Hill right now
they're bootephant in large muddy come
on boys
60 foot of fish
I think we got what we want on here baby
look good look good / look good call
motors her name Destin get these lines
up get these lines up now off the watch
you dragged I'm gonna come around here
all right come on girl
55 it
it's coming up Austin I see cooler but
you gotta take the shot when you get it
it's gonna be a nice fish high-sticking
did a lot of head shake and go home come
on you gotta get him now what oh come
now
everything is gone you're kidding no
golly
Dave how the world did that happen you
telling me dude dude it looked like a
park for dart shot it was whose fish
like this it's devastating paycheck you
swimming away so close to the end of the
season I mean it's like wow I really
just bullet I feel like I left my dad
and came down I mean the fish isn't here
if fish is going I let them down
oh my gosh when you lose a fish it burns
you down it uh it ruins your insides to
a point where you start questioning
yourself what you should never do how in
the world did that happen I don't know
Austin's primary job is the dart the
fist this is a very discouraging loss
major kicking a gun Austin can't make
that mistake again
but there's no sense crying about it we
just need to sit back out and go back
fishing all right come on let's get set
out all right daddy Oh God